[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I want to start the show a
little bit differently today instead of
talking about the day's news which we'll
get to and we've got a very interesting
interview coming up for you today I want
to talk about a topic that's getting
more and more attention and that's the
topic of universal basic income or some
version of it we've talked about a
negative income tax the point is an idea
of a non means-tested source of money
for people regardless of employment with
the potential to lift a significant
number of people out of poverty and if
you've been watching the show for any
length of time you know that I'm in
favor of something like this and
sometimes we've answered audience
questions about what I prefer a
universal basic income or a negative
income tax do I have a preference do I
think that all social welfare benefits
should be eliminated along with their
respective bureaucracies and sort of
consolidated into one non means taxed
tested universal basic income or do we
want to try to target based on income
levels a big picture I believe that
something like it is is simply going to
be a necessity right as we rethink
society in the next 10 to 20 years
really are sort of forced to reset the
briefing society due to automation and
technological unemployment and the
continued destruction of jobs
elimination of jobs as a result of
technological advances and changes to
our sort of socioeconomic status quo but
in the past
I've not just been completely effusive
and a cheerleader of ubi with no caveats
right I've expressed some concerns in
the past about how ubi would actually be
implemented and what the effect would be
or should be or could be and there's a
very interesting article in TruthDig
that i read yes
today which reminded me that this is an
issue I've been wanting to tackle for a
while and why not today and I don't want
to be cynical right and I and I haven't
wanted to be cynical when talking about
ubi in the past but I've said that when
you see a bunch of ultra rich CEOs and
founders of some of the biggest
corporations especially in tech and
e-commerce companies like Microsoft
Amazon Facebook when you see companies
like that and their CEOs and founders
emphatically and enthusiastically for
universal basic basic income
we should be cautiously optimistic right
hoping that they're in favor of it for
the right reasons but we also want to
kind of verify why are they so thrilled
with the idea of universal basic income
in case in point
Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk and
Richard Branson Bill Gates some less
well-known sort of oligarch rich guys
like Stewart Butterfield they've all
expressed that they like the idea of
universal basic income so okay that's
great but we need to really put a
critical eye on why they are so in favor
of it and also how Universal basic
income could be sort of appropriated for
the good of what our kind of modern-day
oligarchs right the ultra-rich founders
of these major corporations and if you
think about one way to think about this
would be to say all right well if we put
in universal basic income what wouldn't
change like what would stay the same if
we put in ubi
and that can start to sort of give us an
idea about why it might be appealing to
some of the biggest corporations on the
planet if you put in ubi business and
market regulation doesn't change it
remains the same living wage
requirements for people who are working
don't change simply because you put in
universal basic income labor conditions
for people working in not great
conditions right whether it's sweatshops
or whatever the case may be labor
conditions aren't automatically upgraded
because everybody gets eight grand a
year or eleven grand a year or whatever
the proposal might say
in universal basic income college is no
more affordable just because you give
people universal basic income other than
sort of by the obvious nature of them
having a little bit more money but the
problem of the explosive cost of a
college education
that doesn't change merely because you
have universal basic income it's simply
not part of it and in fact there are
many companies that say they want
universal basic income that are the same
companies that are creating a need for
it
outsourcing automation pillaging of
natural resources gigantic carbon
footprints some of these companies
eliminate the need for a lot of these
jobs so they would want people receiving
universal basic income because that's
going to give them that customers that
they would otherwise lose if you start
putting people out of work in the United
States because you outsource production
to China for example some of those
people in the US are no longer going to
be able to afford your product or
service anymore
have the government give them a basic
income and now all of a sudden they get
back into the possible pool of your
customers it's perfect and one of the
big tenants or maybe better said one of
the characteristics of neoliberalism is
free market and corporate power setting
up universal basic income could very
easily be used to number one just create
more customers for the corporations
responsible for eliminating a lot of
these jobs and number two universal
basic income could be used to push back
against regulation and minimum wage laws
and other Pro worker laws right why do
we need to raise the minimum wage we
just put in place universal basic income
let's keep the minimum wage really low
which benefits these really large
corporations except that by keeping the
minimum wage low the corporation's keep
making their executives richer off of
profits at the expense of paying workers
a living wage and they can hide behind
the creation of ubi and in fact we
already see this right companies like
McDonald's
Walmart we've talked about these
companies already in part get away with
paying the terrible wages and benefits
that they pay because lots of their
employees get food stamps and other
social welfare benefits from the
government Social Welfare subsidizes the
terrible wages that some of these very
profitable companies pay in the United
States and UB I could make that way
worse the so called gig economy right
driving for uber and lyft as an example
major problems they're taking advantage
of contractors rather than making the
drivers employees we need to be looking
at a lot of elements of what's going on
there
throw in a basic income give everybody
nine thousand eleven thousand thirteen
thousand dollars a year well why are we
gonna now get involved in making lyft
and uber change their model yeah
working for them doesn't pay that much
but we passed ubi don't go after them
now everybody's got their eight thousand
bucks as a base this isn't an argument
against universal basic income to be
clear this is a word of caution
now that ubi is getting more and more
attention it's a word of caution that we
need to think critically about this and
really think about how it would work in
practice now is there a particular
answer or solution that I'm bringing up
no actually I don't know right what I
can tell you is that universal basic
income needs to work in concert with
other really significant structural
changes to our society that quite
frankly I'm pretty skeptical we're gonna
be making anytime soon and I remain
completely convinced about the need for
something like a universal basic income
or a negative income tax or some other
proposal some of some others of which
I've been reviewing and will talk to you
about but I'm just as as as convinced
that just dropping nine thousand dollars
in everybody's pocket every year or
eleven thousand dollars isn't going to
fix a lot of the structural problems
that we have in our socio-economic
reality and at its core when you give
everybody nine thousand dollars you do
nothing to deal with the problem of in
and wealth inequality which has economic
consequences it has social consequences
it has psychological consequences that
we've talked about about just these
drastic and growing disparities between
rich and poor so what I would like to
hear from you is specifically what else
needs to happen in concert with a
universal basic income to actually make
this something that would be a net
benefit in total aside from just again
dropping nine thousand dollars in
people's laps which i think is a good
thing i think that ubi and these concert
concepts are something that is they're
not only good ideas they're gonna be
necessary ideas in the next ten to
twenty years in the United States but
they're not going to do anything about
so many of the other problems that we
have and what we need to be a hundred
person I needs to be crystal clear as we
advocate for ubi that it cannot be used
by the rich and by big corporations and
by oligarchs to say we don't need to
regulate we don't need living wage we
don't need to do anything else because
we did drop nine thousand bucks into
everybody's pocket that's my concern at
this point I do wonder whether or not
the universal basic income would be
entirely good for the rich in
corporations though because the ubi
would be redistributed right I mean
those that money would have to come from
somewhere it would likely come from the
rich so maybe they would see their taxes
increase so when people like Mark
Zuckerberg or Elon Musk come out and say
we're in favor of universal basic income
maybe they are just acting in the best
interest of the country and want to pay
it forward yeah I mean most of the
proposals wouldn't require an increase
in taxes because you would just
reshuffle other programs that are out
there and you might even actually save
money because you would eliminate the
bureaucracies required for a lot of
those programs so welfare state so in
that case it actually it wouldn't
necessarily have that effect but we'll
follow it I'm interested in hearing from
the audience what your thoughts are I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show the
David Pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is ronald pearson ronald thank you
we do depend on the support of members
like ronald and we also depend on the
support of not only new members but our
longtime sustaining members and today's
sustaining member of the day is cam
McNeely cam has been with us for years
and years and I remember when cam first
signed up in fact and he's been with us
ever since it feels like just yesterday
cam even though it has been at this
point close to 7 years going on seven
years join ronald and cam by becoming
members at david pakman.com slash
membership we have a coupon code vote
soon 18 which will save you 40% we're
also trying to get 500 new financial
supporters in order to expand the show
increase the number of shows and the
duration of every show you can do that
by becoming a member you can also do it
by being a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show or by becoming a
sponsor of our youtube channel at
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
this is something really funny last
night I was browsing the David Pakman
show subreddit and there was a thread
that someone made pointing out that
there should be sort of a David Pakman
show
bingo of sorts showing that there are a
few different catchphrases a sort of
drinking game or bingo of the game any
time david says says the phrase or words
gong show abortive or depraved listeners
have to take a shot and this gave me the
idea that we should actually develop
like a david pakman show bingo board I
don't know what we would do with it we
could turn it into like a thousand-piece
puzzle we could send it out as a sort of
poster print I don't know what exactly
we would do with it and the the reddit
participant is including some good ones
I think also on it would have to be if I
accidentally punch my mic that would
have to be like the center square which
sometimes happens when I get very very
impassioned
about a story I think I say vile quite a
bit depraved is a good one
shows a good one and so is abortive
asking a live caller if they're on
speakerphone should definitely be a box
on the bingo board joking about how
infrequently I mentioned membership I
think might be something that could be
on there quite frankly is another phrase
that I tend to use a lot any number of
is of course a long time classic that
goes back a long ways but I don't know
what else should be on it right and I'm
curious to hear from the audience and I
don't even know like is a bingo board
looks like there are they five by five
is what it looks like from this picture
so we need 25 total phrases or words I
think we can get to 20 yeah I've got a
few too it's a whole thing and then you
also like to impersonate Trump a lot
yeah so many many could be a square
Bigley or big league yeah although I
don't know that it shouldn't when if I'm
satirically using someone else's
catchphrase I think that's a little
dishonest for a bingo board because they
should really be my phrases now that
ones that I've sort of jokingly
appropriated from someone else if we do
this you have to like tune that out
though you can't think about the bingo
board because otherwise there'll be some
like inherent bias there yeah I know
I'll be very losing words they're
choosing not to say some words right but
presumably the bingo boards are
randomized so that not everyone has the
same board and that way cuz otherwise
everybody wins at the same time right as
long as they're there paying attention
so write in tell me what other words and
phrases should should be there any
number I know that there are lots of
others maybe one would be when a hatred
uses your instead of your like you
apostrophe re versus why oh you are like
that would be part of the bingo a bingo
item I'm open okay so get in touch
comment on the YouTube video for this
story comment on that reddit thread at
david pakman.com slash re d di t email
me tweet me whatever i'm gonna start
putting together a list and once we get
25 good ones we'll figure out something
to do with the bingo board i think it's
gonna be a stunningly good idea maybe
you get a free bingo board with a new
membership in the future or something
like that okay big breaking news story
according to the Kremlin Donald Trump
has invited Vladimir Putin to the White
House and you might say well who cares
we should want better relationships with
Russia
we should want to be Russia's friend
this is great yay
and then we get back to reality and we
learned that this reportedly happened
during that same phone call a couple of
weeks ago where after being told do not
congratulate Vladimir Putin on his sham
election win Donald Trump did exactly
that congratulated Vladimir Putin on his
win mentioned nothing about election
meddling mentioned nothing about the
continued suspicious deaths of Russian
dissidents around the world and the
claim about this invitation to maybe
come to the White House for Vladimir
Putin came from a Kremlin aide named
Yuri ochakov who said that Russian who
said to Russian journalists that quote
if everything will be alright
I hope that the Americans will not back
away from their own proposal to discuss
the possibility of holding a summit when
our president spoke on the phone it was
trump who proposed holding the first
meeting in Washington in the White House
Putin hasn't been to the White House
since 2005
when george w bush was president when
the US and russia i guess sort of had a
better relationship you could say so why
do we care well we care because this is
vladimir putin's manipulation of donald
trump bearing fruit right it's another
example of putin getting what he wants
which is be being seen as a sort of
serious world leader that gets invited
and the red carpet is rolled out for
them and they get to go into the most
special of places although certainly the
white the Oval Office has become less
special since Donald Trump has
appropriated it what better situation
for Putin than a long in-person meeting
with Trump on Trump's own turf were
Putin who is very skilled will use his
skills to manipulate Trump and even even
when you look at how we found out about
this right even the release of this news
by Russia is part of the ploy to
embarrass Trump and just create chaos
because now it's win-win for Vladimir
Putin if Trump admits yeah I I did say
that he could come to the White House
well why wasn't it mentioned
and why would Trump do it and why would
he reward Russia with inviting Vladimir
Putin to the White House and then if
Trump denies it it immediately calls
into question whether Trump is lying
something that he does a lot and if so
it would make us wonder why is this
something that Trump would lie about
which only increases more of the
suspicion about what's going on with
Russia the fact that we're first hearing
about this from Russia is sort of part
of the chaos that Russia is so expertly
catalyzing and we once again we've got
to apply Trump's razor to this as I
mentioned yesterday no matter what you
believe the limits of geopolitical
stupidity to be the current
administration the Trump administration
will act in the most ignorant and stupid
way possible to the point that you will
be shocked and in fact the most likely
scenario is that we get initially a
denial from the Trump administration
followed by a White House visit by
Vladimir Putin and then there will never
actually be a follow-up question about
wait I thought you'd deny that you had
invited him to him here the way it
always goes is is some version of that
right we hear from the Washington Post
or the New York Times something that
sounds totally nuts then you know Trump
uses his bathtub as a toilet or
something that sounds absolutely nutty
White House immediately condemns says
the president would never use his
bathtub as a toilet it's the fake news
media including that failing fake news
Amazon Jeff Bezos Washington Post
they're smearing the president then like
two days later Trump goes to Twitter and
says hey yeah alright I use my bathtub
as a toilet and Hillary was using her
bathtub as a toilet before I did and the
FBI refuses to look into when Hillary
Clinton is using her bathtub as a toilet
no one cares about that and I've been
treated very very unfairly and then the
sort of cherry on top is three days go
by and then Trump says why I never said
I used my bathtub as a toilet I was
misquoted by the loser New York Times I
never said it and then a hundred grand
goes to another pornstar in hush money
and we all forget about it because we're
like 10 scandals past it that is the
sort of mo of how these things develop
will we
ever hear about it again I genuinely
don't know I wanted to talk about this
yesterday but didn't have time last week
after weeks and weeks of not taking
questions in a press conference after
days of having nothing public on his
calendar whatsoever Trump decided to do
basically a campaign rally he went to
Ohio to do a rally in front of a
friendly crowd it's kind of like what
you do when you're running for president
supposedly it was going to be an
infrastructure speech by the way how
often is it infrastructure week it seems
like almost every week in this
administration is infrastructure week
Trump went completely and totally off
the rails it turned into a very strange
garbled rant resembling the English
language only loosely and demonstrating
a sort of Sarah Palin like inability to
communicate anything of meaning through
language and it got so bad that the
three major cable networks CNN MSNBC and
Fox News all just cut away from the
speech although you'll be pleased to
know that good old Fox Business Network
stayed with the entire thing all the way
through here is Fox bailing when it got
weird former george w bush white house
press secretary dana perino who's now a
fox news anchor fittingly explaining
that they are going away and she looked
sort of in physical pain as she said it
32,000 soldiers are even watching
president Russell is in Ohio giving a
speech wide-ranging speech but mostly
focusing on his infrastructure plan and
former White House deputy chief of staff
Karl Rove is back with me I like that
wide-ranging is code for Trump is all
over the place real quick go to Karl
Rove to try to say this save us here so
even Fox cutting away even though they
did stay with it a few minutes longer
than CNN and MSNBC so here just random
weird moments the entire speech was
totally off the rails all right here's
just a random 20 seconds of Trump from
the speech we're very important and
respected in some circles Democrat said
we want to get rid we should get rid of
our Second Amendment in other words get
rid of it that's really
good sir could be right about that so
we're going to protect our Second
Amendment that's not going to happen we
have the best judges we put on a
tremendous amount of great federal
district court judges will be setting
records we are setting records appeals
court judges Supreme Court judge
fantastic justice Gorsuch what is he
talking about setting records like what
what the hell is this guy on just
another few seconds from Trump's bizarre
speech that networks couldn't even stay
with it and we didn't have one Democrat
who voted for that they want to raise
your taxes and they want people to come
in from the border and they want I guess
want I can't imagine they want but
certainly drugs are flowing across
borders we need walls we started
building our wall I'm so proud of it I
started we started we have 1.6 billion
and we've already started you saw the
pictures yesterday I said what a thing
of beauty and on September 28th we go
further yeah that was a lie by the way
the pictures he's referring to were from
the replacement of two miles of border
fence dating back to the 1990s we've got
one more clip again just disjointed
rantings of a madman we spent and I was
against it from the beginning they try
and say well maybe not I was against it
from the beginning
and by the way we're knocking the hell
out of Isis will be coming out of Syria
like very soon let the other people take
care of it now very soon very soon we're
coming out we're gonna have a hundred
percent of the Caliphate as they call it
sometimes referred to as land take it
all back quickly quickly but we're gonna
be coming out of there real soon gonna
get back to our country where we belong
where we want to be but just think of it
we spent as of three months ago seven
trillion dollars not billion not million
seven trillion with at ease nobody ever
heard of the word trillion until 10
years ago
we spent seven trillion dollars in the
Middle East we'd build a school that
blow it up we'd build it again they'd
blow it up we'd build it again
has it been blown up yet but it will be
but if we want a school in Ohio to fix
the windows you can't get the money if
you want a school in Pennsylvania or
Iowa to get federal money you can't get
the money we spent seven trillion
dollars in the Middle East and you know
we have for it nothing remember I used
to say keep the oil as a civilian
I used to say did anybody hear me say
that that's before I decided to go in
this journey with all of you I got tired
of watching what on earth is this guy
talking about i it is the disjointed
rantings of someone who understands
nothing it's always infrastructure week
or month or whatever nothing actually
happens except Trump just showing up and
talking about is random random musings
here and it's there's two phases of a
Trump speech there's the horrible syntax
of the teleprompter reading where he's
looking off at an angle and saying and
if we were to become a better nation of
and then we would write like it's just
you can't read it it just makes no sense
whatsoever and then you see when he
shifts off the teleprompter and look
straight ahead and but then you don't
even know what the guys talking about
because he's just completely off the
rails and improvising and I hope that
soon we actually get a press conference
supposedly he's doing one today
questions like mr. president can you
just say definitively did you have sex
with stormy Daniels did you realize that
your people were knowingly and directly
dealing with Russian intelligence
officers did you know about the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars that Michael
Cohen paid stormy Daniels have you
reimbursed some specific questions and
you you can't put him out there because
he could end up saying something
horribly self incriminating so I hope we
get a press conference soon these
speeches are so bizarre
that even Fox News had to cut away from
it even if he did get those questions
though I think he would go off on a
tangent about how he won the 2016
election it was greatest victory of all
time
they'll maybe got to deflect maybe he
would but I think he would very likely
end up saying something totally totally
self incriminating and it's pretty clear
they're trying to keep him away from
those types of questions hopefully he
will get some today bizarre speech that
a lot of people on our subreddit notice
then you can join that discussion you
can stomach it at david pakman.com slash
re GDIT the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the David
Pakman show I'm joined today by Kelly
Jones who was previously married to Alex
Jones of Infowars Fame we've been
covering some of what has been going on
with Alex Jones over the last 6 to 12
months and Kelly is here to shed some
more light on - really a lot of
different things and Kelly I know that
this has just been not a good moment for
you and for your family in many ways so
first of all I just I really appreciate
you talking to me today thank you so
much for having me on David so I don't
even really know where to begin so I'll
just pick somewhere and and we'll sort
of go from there
you were married to Alex Jones at at a
certain point we learned that you have
concerns as to how your son Rex may be
manipulated or brainwashed by Alex Jones
some of our audience may know that Rex
has been participating in some Infowars
content and I've even received emails
from people sort of concerned about
what's going on there so I mean big
picture
generally speaking what's your sort of
biggest concern around the kids right
now
well David as many people are aware last
year in April 2017 a jury decided for me
to be primary parent to our three
beautiful children
this was after years of family
litigation incepted primarily by Alex I
was on the defense for years I had less
and drug dealers and prostitutes went
from being the primary caregiver to
these kids to having almost no access to
a jury victory spent you know every cent
I had liquid getting that victory and
the judge who acted with such tremendous
bias in the case actually just left the
kids primarily with Alex so number one I
don't think America understands that and
I'm so sad to even hear my son's name on
the air I've fought really hard to keep
their privacy and their innocence
protected throughout all this and I
realize like when things happened last
week when things started coming out I
said some really you know strong words I
mean my son is actively apparently like
watching my Twitter account which breaks
my heart I've told him he's not allowed
but the bottom line is this the judge
basically kept all footage from Infowars
from coming in before the jury this
footage included Alex drunk raging
threatening making a felonious threat to
congressman Schiff saying you know
basically challenging him to a duel was
- there's a speculation that was
felonious and really concerning things
and then Alex got up on the stand and
said he was an actor and that all of the
info war stuff was irrelevant I'm here
to tell America number one that was a
great travesty of justice a bias trial
in the first place but despite all that
from what I showed the evidence was so
concerning to the jury that they said
these kids need to go with her mama and
the judge has just left them there and
clearly it is all about Infowars
if you're a child of Alex Jones's in his
household that is the plan that's laid
out before you and it's it's a heartache
you know so Kelly let me see unbeliev
important things that I want to go
through piece by piece you referenced
this concept that during the trial there
was the assertion made and you can
correct me I I had read that it was by
Alex Jones attorney but you're saying
Alex made it but in either case there's
this idea that you can't evaluate him in
the real world based on what you see on
Infowars because that's sort of a
performance it's a character that he's
playing now let me lay out the following
question for you I met Alex at a radio
conference years and years ago
my impression was because of how he
acted there in private compared to how
he acts on the program that he is sort
of playing a character on the program
that maybe he doesn't believe in all of
these conspiracy theories that maybe he
is sort of playing it up are you here
today able to tell us whether or not
this is a character or the real Alex
Jones that is seen on the program well
first of all I want to remind your
audience that any testimony under oath
is is your word and if it's a lie it's
aggravated perjury and it should be
criminally tried regarding whether or
not it's a persona apparently in court
is a persona when it behooves him to try
to get child custody but then the next
day he goes on his own program to say no
I'm not a performance actor I'm a
performance actor when I play you know
lizard man or whatever but really in
real life I care about all these things
as a former member of his household and
knowing even now how my children have
very concerning views about many
different things the the the paranoia
the the bizarre concepts are definitely
a living in Alex Jones and in his
household but beyond that I would say
that the really concerning behaviors
that affect you know children's
development or a family's development
the violence the rage the anger those
are worse in private life right yeah so
you're looking at his best self on the
air so Kelly you know you never see
writing you never saw anything in the
private Alex Jones that suggested that
the conspiracy theories that he espouses
and all of that stuff are a joke or for
the show as far as you know all of those
beliefs are actually sincerely held
beliefs I mean listen I actively had to
homeschool my kids I actively had to my
kids are I don't want to say that
actually because that would violate
their privacy but there's a lot of
things in my life that I would not have
done if I had not been married to Alex
Jones absolutely like he believes all
that stuff and worse and it's really all
he cares about he doesn't really have
have any other interests or any other
life he's just a cocoon of paranoia and
narcissism disputing it you know
superimposing these feelings over his
family and his entourage
I wouldn't say friends I don't know that
he really has any real friends everyone
around it was highly paid but you know
it which is sad I'm not saying that to
diss him you know I'm not here to
disparage him he's a guy with serious
problems that instead of being helped by
the court or people that could have
helped our family they empowered his
narcissistic rage so if he's not
thinking about it he's watching himself
think about it basically is what I was
going to say it's a mess and it's it's
horrible to be around was there a period
let me put it a different way
did you always question the conspiracy
theories and the beliefs that were
circulating in your household from Alex
Jones did you have a phase where you
were basically indoctrinated into the
same stuff and you broke out of it in
some way I mean absolutely I was
indoctrinated I moved back to Austin for
my my best friend was dying and I was in
a very vulnerable state in my life I had
actually just been working for PETA I
was also disillusioned about that so I
came back to Austin and met this guy he
was kind of interesting we had a show
with the same producer on access TV and
you know it was he was just real
different than anybody I'd ever met and
slowly over time it became you know you
need to come work for me in the house
you need to do this and I was like I
don't know you know and I was 29 I was
definitely not completely thinking
everything through and a few of later
after the boiling water turned up to me
you know the the Frog he always talks
about in the pot right suddenly I was
living in a domestically violent
situation completely isolated from all
friends and family I tried to leave
repeatedly over the years but I would
say at the beginning I definitely
assimilated some of that and that's part
of the reason why I'm talking out I
would say I'm responsible for helping
Alex with his initial success because my
background was in grassroots publicity
so I helped him get on the wire for the
first time I got him his first big gest
but as he sort of progressed or should
we say regress or deteriorated I mean
the Alex Jones you see today is actually
very different than the original Alex
Jones and I would say definitely by the
time
September 11th came around and I was
standing in the front of our street with
the candle my heart broken for our
nation like everyone else and he was
ranting and raging I really I was like
whoa I don't understand what this is
about and I did file many years prior
it's I understand that people might not
have a lot of sympathy for me and I get
that you know I I do understand that and
I'm sorry for whatever part I've had to
play but I'm here also to tell people
like this is reached a concerning level
and some of you can see for some of the
tweets you know and I'm kind of getting
on another path here but he's become an
incredibly powerful guy and his paranoia
and conspiracy that was always
nonpartisan has shifted and to really
just he's a propaganda mouthpiece
there's no other way to look at him and
that mere fact shocks everybody but yes
I say by the time my last child was born
or my youngest child around 10 years ago
I was not listening to the show I was
actively opposed to it and just really
disgusted actually by the content I was
still somewhat involved in the business
for sure you know management stuff and I
tried to leave it's all I can say you
know Kelly so as far as the inclusion of
one of your kids on the program that is
just publicly viewable to anybody as of
late and again it's something people in
my audience have expressed concern about
what do you make of it I mean is it do
you think that your son is is sort of
being coerced into doing this is it a
question of wanting to do it but because
in some way he's been brainwashed by
your ex-husband like what do you make of
that well I would say a hundred percent
you know that this child first of all
alex is in complete violation of court
order he's enjoying from broadcasting my
son and he's enjoying from making
unilateral decisions about my son my son
I never see and at the time of the
verdict he was really happy to see me
and
what's come into play with the case
which is relevant to your question is
this phenomenon called parental
alienation parental alienation is a
systematic abusive horribly
psychologically abusive behaviors that
effectively turn children against one
parent turns kids against the other one
yeah I mean I think it's pretty common
people understand that in the sort of
vernacular but Rex you know he has never
had a chance he's he's brilliant
my son he's so smart and he was so
exuberant and engaged and I think that
beyond the endangerment which it really
does endanger him there really are cooks
out there that both are like go get him
tiger and are saying way worse things
than that to him yeah but beyond that
he's just been groomed for this role for
years and years and I said something I
was talking to somebody the other day
it's like it say you were a car salesman
and you only liked a certain brand of
car and at 12 years old you told your
kid this is what you're gonna do for
your life you're gonna sell this car and
this is the only car you're gonna like
and all of the cars are terrible and
that you made that kid get on and
broadcast at 8:15 I think people would
have a problem with that children need
to develop their identity independently
of their parents it came out in court
and therefore I can say it that Alex has
a narcissistic personality disorder and
a big component of that is this overlay
over the kids where kids have to our
family members need to reflect you you
know he's brilliant my son he wanted to
be a personal trainer he told me he
wanted his first car to be a Prius
because he didn't want it his way pay
for him he wanted to make his own way
and I think that that's a little bit out
the window now and he's all over still
like big media and it's I'm so worried
about him
you know I'm so worried about him Kelly
let's pause the conversation there were
speaking with Kelly Jones she was
previously married to Alex Jones
for Wars Fame and we'll continue our
conversation at where we left off the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I love the story the Catholic Church and
the Vatican are now scrambling after
Pope Francis sort of appeared to
question whether there even is a hell
which is kind of a pretty basic belief
of Catholicism but you don't have to
worry because the flunkies are claiming
he was just misunderstood what happened
is that during a recent meeting Eugenio
Scalf re who's the now 93 year old
founder of a Vatican newspaper asked
Pope Francis where do bad Souls go of
course the correct answer in the context
of the Catholic Church is supposed to be
while they go to hell and Pope Francis
is quoted by Scalf Ari as saying quote
they are not punished those who repent
obtain God's forgiveness and take their
place among the ranks of those who
contemplate him but those who do not
repent and cannot be forgiven disappear
a hell doesn't exist the disappearance
of sinning souls exists this led to
panic at the Vatican that should be a
name for a funny romantic comedy panic
at the Vatican and if you're the Vatican
you you sort of need the threat of
eternity in hell to get people to fall
in line right this is one of the ways in
which you get people to do what you want
them to do is convince them that if they
don't do what you want them to do that
they're gonna end up spending an
eternity in hell they are writing this
off as a misquote but they're not even
offering an alternative meaning they're
just saying quotes of the Pope are not
accurate the Vatican said that the quote
literal words pronounced by the Pope are
not quoted and that quote no quotation
of the article should be considered as a
faithful transcription of the words of
the Holy Father then the other
interpretation explaining what's going
on here is that what he meant
isn't that hell doesn't exist but that
hell as a place of fire and brimstone
and misery isn't real like there's no
hell if you imagine the burning Inferno
but there is how if it's just separation
from God and the disappearance of the
soul or something like that but then
you're really finding an explanation it
just fit what
was that was allegedly said here the
problem with that is that there are
endless poor trails of Hell by Catholics
as exactly a place of fire and brimstone
in their own scriptures in the book of
Revelation in Corinthians anyway I don't
really care about the specifics I just
love how this Pope who is from Argentina
by the way has thrown the Catholic
Church into these moments of chaos as a
result of just steering away even
slightly from some of the orthodoxy of
the church and the one sort of caveat
here is that the interviewer scull fari
Eugenio Scalf re he does have somewhat
of a history of being I guess I'll call
it fast and loose with the truth in some
cases but it still seems weird that he
would make up an interview whole cloth
but both from a sort of marketing and PR
perspective for his newspaper and from a
legal perspective but this is a super
interesting because we've been following
the move away from Catholicism that's
been going on you've seen people leaving
Catholicism because they've stopped
being religious altogether right like
that's one layer which is in general
particularly younger generations are
becoming less and less religious over
time but there's this whole other angle
which is that there are Catholics who
have also just left Catholicism and
moved to Protestantism meaning non
Catholic Christianity and part of it has
to do with the specifics of the Catholic
Church and it's sort of feeling quite
frankly there's one of those possible
bingo phrases quite frankly like a dated
and sort of in in downfall organization
even though they still have like 1.2 1.3
billion adherents so it's gonna be an
interesting decade I think for the
Catholic Church upcoming yeah and I
think that's why we're seeing such a
progressive Pope in Pope Francis I mean
the guy seems to be ok with gay marriage
accepts that climate change exists it's
just interesting how saying that hell
doesn't exist is a bridge too far for
these Catholics yeah and there's the
last straw we can have the straight-up
panicking and saying that's simply not
what he said send me your thoughts I
know that there are current and ex
Catholics in the show audience and I'd
be interested in hearing from them for
sure we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two days
P here is a voicemail that came in
yesterday but hey David I was wondering
if you think that the trend towards you
know more autumn autumn Atty x'd warfare
when using drones and stuff like that
isn't a net benefit over you know the
traditional method of just going and
doing on-the-ground warfare I guess
there's a sense that yeah there's a
disconnect that comes from using drones
but at the same time I guess it does
save more a lot more American lives what
do you think about that what in terms of
the pros and cons
yeah well listen you're absolutely right
this is a really important topic you're
absolutely right that drone warfare
saves American lives that's absolutely
true because Americans are able now to
go and carry out a military operation
with no boots on the ground and not even
with pilots in the air right just with
literally remote-controlled aerial
vehicles controlled by a pilot sitting
in front of a computer somewhere so that
certainly reduces the death toll of some
of these operations for Americans we are
told by the advocates of drone warfare
that it also reduces the death toll for
our enemies because the precision of
some of these drones allow the American
military to strike only their intended
target and to reduce collateral damage
and civilian deaths how true that is I
definitely have a question about the the
real problem with drone warfare is sort
of a psychological one and the
disconnect that exists because if you
are boots on the ground
you could still carry out actions that
are humanitarian in nature you could
carry out actions that are totally
deplorable in nature but you have a
completely different connection to what
it is that you're doing then if you are
sitting somewhere in the United States
or on an army base in Germany or
wherever the case may be piloting what
effectively is a remote-control airplane
and the sort of technology ization I
know that's not a word but the
technology of warfare in the
waise I think is very very problematic
in terms of how it might influence what
standards and practices we use to
determine when we are going to do
something and when we are not going to
do something and of course that doesn't
mean there aren't rules of engagement it
doesn't mean that there aren't legal
mechanisms that that are sort of
overriding and controlling a lot of what
it is that's going on here so to get
back to the initial question because
that's really what I want to get to and
your question was in the net do I think
that drone warfare is a benefit or not I
think that if you're thinking in very
concrete short term style you can say
fewer people are probably dying when we
use drones as opposed to other forms of
military incursion the long term answer
may be a very different one where we are
seeing a continued sort of devaluing
of the lives of those populations that
we are targeting and in total the
existence of drone warfare also might
make it possible to carry out way more
incursions in geographically disparate
areas so I think that in the short term
fewer people are dying over the long
term I'm not at all convinced that this
is a positive development but it's
something we've done interviews around
before and that I certainly plan to
continue covering on the bonus show
today we will talk about the teachers
strike across Oklahoma based around
compensation and wages I'm going to talk
about a trump official asking Congress
to start raining in a consumer watchdog
agency no surprise at all that that's
going on and also Grindr the gay dating
app has decided to stop sharing HIV
status to third-party vendors
third-party vendors vendors and
advertisers used to be able to actually
target ads to users of the platform that
disclose their potentially hiv-positive
status which of course would be relevant
in the dating sphere but also would make
them potential targets for particular
products and services and Grindr has
decided they're no longer going to allow
their third-party vendors to have access
to that information
we will be talking about that and much
more on today's bonus show which you can
get access to by signing up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we do have a 40% off coupon
code that you can take advantage of it
is vote soon 18 and you can also make a
pledge on patreon to get access to the
bonus show at patreon.com slash david
pakman show thanks for watching today
we'll talk to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you